Stefon Diggs back here in the red eyes
and show how you been Stefan you got it
so walk me through this when did you
first learn that Sam Bradford might
suddenly not be able to go for you guys
Oh late in the week because you know he
did practice he did he did throw the
ball around during a week just like the
previous week so we kind of got the news
pretty late they know in the week but
you know when we got it we were excited
for taste a second opportunity you know
I feel like he was he was better than
showing showed it and then this week how
were things different just cuz he had a
full week of practice with you guys is
that as simple as that Stefan no
football wise but you know he practiced
a lot last week as well I feel like no
here they played in the game in a while
and you know that could play a factor
begin a way played a factor
remember we had a home game we had a
good amount of time to prepare he
already had a game on his own he had
things he wanted to get done so I think
the energy that he was bringing out that
day was just special well how has the
offense improved as a whole I guess from
last year to this because you have now
two home games where we've you've lit it
up and we could technically based on the
circumstances of week to just toss that
one out yeah especially initially for
the winning games a losing game
everybody's a contender you can lose
anybody but I would say this team you
know we just try to play together
we're pulling each other up you know
we're down you know staying motivated
standing and standing the positive light
on the style on every throughout the
game so 100 versatility we don't get
down on ourselves
well Stefon Diggs here on the Rich Eisen
show how is Sam Bradford what can you
tell me good good I mean from what I
know you know I don't know too much
about anything injuries and stuff like
that but I talked to him he seems good
in good spirits you mean is that what
you're saying or is there anything in
general I mean I talked to me that you
know he always has a smile you know
always good energy coming from does he
expect to play this week I mean what
what do you what are you hearing about
that I have no idea okay alright what's
the scoop on Bridgewater
has he been around have you seen him
come to meetings he comes though so he's
always at the games my studies are home
games but he's at all the
it gives all the coaching points that he
cares for like assisting us especially
when when he can at least as far as like
if he see something he gives us a head
that would try this so make sure you do
that type of thing please he's always
there ever since he went down it always
seems with your team it's one thing or
another his injury Sam Bradford's
acquisition his ascendency then his
injury then your coach having to leave
the sidelines because of his eye and
requiring surgery and then now this year
where Bradford starts well hurt keenham
in how do you guys deal with this I
think it's more uh we kind of used to
and now far to have a next man up
mentality and have a season ago that we
do have you know um because things will
happen
you know our coach does this all the
time that ever she's gonna strike not
only on the field but you know anything
to happen you know we didn't news like
Samuel or town we can't we can't talk we
can't be sad about we gotta make things
work and we got to put faith in the guy
that we do have in place like a case you
see how baby stepped up when he hasn't
really in behind a minute he's bringing
a positive energy so I was there playing
for one another issues Stefon Diggs here
on the Rich Eisen show fresh off of a
173 yards two touchdowns for the
two-on-one Vikings who are taking on the
two and one lines in their house this
week we'll get to that week for game in
a second here Stefan I do want to hit
you up on the president Trump's comments
from Friday night how did that land in
your locker room um you know as far as
the statements you know I turned out to
go anything with politics going on I am
a notable organization and I do share a
lot four different beliefs but at the
end of day after like what's right is
right and wrong is wrong and all I got
honey no matter what's being said and we
stick together and we want to keep it
that way
well I'm hearing the message of unity
across the the NFL and in the same way
that I'm sitting here saying it's it's
everyone's right to kneel the on the
national anthem to make a point start a
conversation it's the same person's
right to say I want to stand for the
national
and it means that much to me and I want
to be out on the field standing for the
national anthem
are there some people in your locker
room that are saying that and that's
part of the unity discussion well game
we are it wasn't a discussion at all we
are together wherever we want to do it
on door together no matter what no
matter how we do it on where we are do
it we chose our lock arms and after we
chose to do so and are you concerned
that there are some fans out there in
Minnesota country and skull Vikings
country that are gonna just be turned
off by this conversation and no longer a
fan of the team I will necessarily be
concerned I also say it's unfortunate
because uh you know every man every man
has a right to do he believes and if he
wants to take a knee in all them do
anything for that matter
he used to do so especially if he says
is right because it's a lot going on in
the world and on the right is right and
wrong and if taking the knee is the
first step is I believe it should be
done other than that
mm if you don't see it and if a person's
not doing anything malicious or doing
anything to hurt anybody and you take an
offense to it I kind of feel like maybe
you might be the problem as well you
know because the people are you know
taking action for just wanting things to
be different Alaska cues changed and if
you keep going to get change as far as I
wanted something right or wanting
something to be done I kind of view it
you might be a part of the problem as
well
Stefon Diggs Minnesota Vikings receiver
here on the Rich Eisen show how far do
you think this team can go here
mm sighs representing the team you know
we're gonna take your game to the top
but uh good things can happen you
executing you get things done you know
this week we got a new opponent we got a
new focus we trying get a jump start
early so I watch them closely see where
they've been doing the past couple weeks
and try to get out on them well I mean
you guys know where the Super Bowl is
taking place this year is there any open
conversation and then the road
we more than excited and more they have
Stefon Diggs here on the Rich Eisen show
how weird was it to have Adrian Peterson
in a different uniform in that building
to start the season different I'm
probably more so far thesis of gods
because they had to tackle them for once
but he never did never got to tackle
never so for them it's probably a sight
to see but for me it was just you know I
was happy for him you know happy for his
new journey happy for a new chapter and
I was nothing but that said his record
for the most yards rushing as a Vikings
player in his first three games that
record is now toast because Dalvin cook
past it with now 288 rushing yards that
is 17 more than Peterson's record how
good is Dalvin cook Stefon special
that's one word that can describe that
young man and as far as what he brings
to the table his approach to the game
and you know his energy you know I speak
energy in existence a lot because I feel
like you can play off of this far like
when you're QB comes in with that
positive mindset your running back comes
in with a mindset and we come to work we
come to get things done and we come to
execute so bring that to the table I
love them back they're you know they're
trying to push some girls around for
alright lastly Stefon this is not your
first foray o in the Rich Eisen show as
you know we dodge you up when you were
just a mere pup in this league you know
it's year three but you were you're
breaking out and were like you know what
I want to meet Stefon Diggs I want the
listeners and viewers of this show to
get to know Stefon Diggs so I'm saying
that to set up this last question
Stephane I care about you okay you do
you do realize the relaxed celebration
rules does not mean you rely so much you
start celebrating before you actually
school you know I got this conversation
at least a hundred times now so the care
is coming from a good place and I
appreciate I'm gonna make sure doesn't
have no I know you held it up like prime
and you started slowing down did you
hear about this from Mike Zimmer did get
in the end zone unlike your colleague
from Chicago I know if you saw Marcus
Cooper get the ball knocked away at the
one-yard line against Pittsburgh yeah I
heard a lot of people were worried
because it did see that play it does
be a remake um I'm lucky enough that
kind of I saw him I'm not gonna say I
didn't see him I saw him and I was
looking up you know get an end zone but
I did hear this I'm not gonna tell you
the things that he said to me but are
you saying it was not safe for Mike
Zimmer work words are you saying I don't
know what they were they were all
definitely you know where's the lips are
moving forward okay
you work blue in purple that's what
you're saying
a little bit okay very good
thanks for calling in Stefan let's chat
again soon okay
down the line good luck against the
lines the Rich Eisen show weekdays at
noon eastern on radio stations across
the country and audience if you like
that video be sure to download our app
and I'll be sure to help the NFL figure
out what it catches